another country moving to ease its
restrictions is India after imposing the
world's biggest lockdown covering 1.3
billion people the government has now
given the go-ahead for states with no
new cases to relax their restrictions
agriculture and some industry is able to
meet social distancing and hygiene norms
will be allowed to reopen but for much
of the country the lockdown will
continue for weeks to come
Prime Minister Narendra Modi has urged
Indians to be patient
warning that the virus does not see
Court race religion color cast creed
language or borders that statement from
the Prime Minister comes as criticism
grows that the government isn't doing
enough to stop the vilification and
stigmatization of Muslims over the
coronavirus the targeting of Muslims as
spreaders of kovat 19 began mainly after
a number of cases were linked to a
meeting of an Islamic organization in
the capital Delhi in early March on
Friday we asked noted author and rights
activist identity Roy how the situation
was for Muslims in India honestly the
situation is approaching general Seidel
you know because the the government's
agenda has been this I mean since this
cavalcade Muslims have been lynched
Muslims have been hunted down but now
the stigmatization with this illness has
left you know government policies on the
street now we can hear it everywhere and
the the it comes with a threat of
extreme violence Nalin Kohli is a lawyer
and national spokesman for the ruling
BJP he joins me now from a Delhi mr.
Gandhi welcome Alan xxx Roy is saying
that the situation for Muslims is
approaching genocidal would you agree is
false is baseless it's even unreasonable
and so heat stream so let's look at
speak on facts the public II Jamaat and
is an event or an organization that held
an event that resulted in them not
following the homes
and thereafter their members and this is
all reported have been found to be
spitting on doctors when they are
infected they have been excluding I mean
literally Jessica T in the quarantine
and absolute premises ignoring orders
not to do so they have been undressing
and getting mute the four female nurses
and sometimes eggs or resource YouTube I
have read bank tests faith communities
not at all in fact that's the but where
there are real instances that have
happened in which is the capital city
they happened in Ghaziabad in cannot in
in God in many other cities so every
sweet thing which is debunked does not
mean second is let's look at the
comments working the gum for no less
than Prime Minister Modi has said
everyone irrespective of whether they
would our Constitution Accords equality
but since you may be in the prime
minister apologies for cutting in right
now but then Prime Minister Modi also
you should a statement along the same
lines that you mentioned he said that
covert 19 does not see race religion
caste creed language or border before
striking these are his words I mean if
there are if there is no problem with
Muslims and if all these reports of the
harassment are false and baseless what
did the Prime Minister of India have to
make these statements so let me first
come miss Roy in India so let's look at
the real situation also as we have
spoken as we speak 323 million Indian
citizens the forests of the four have
received money into their bank accounts
to enable but you're not answering my
question the question I asked you is if
everything is hunky-dory with Muslims in
India why did the Prime Minister of
India have to make a statement saying
that covert 90 does not see race
religion before
working and he neither does it see
region he's dream for sizing what he is
consistently add that we all need to
cooperate with the lockdown we need to
do so in the interest it is not as if
this virus is a Christian Buddhist
passio Jew so if we break those lockdown
required if we we are not and may I'll
give you another real example a very
popular person on one of the social
media has from the Muslim community
disregarded a face marks and said I'm
protected by God he himself is now
affected by Koval 19 so this appeal is
irrespective whether you are Hindu
Muslim Christian Buddhist passier Jew we
need to observe these things because the
virus does not stop at anyone stop you
speak about social media I mean you
yourself have a big following on social
media
lots of your colleagues in the BJP have
big followings and social media for
example Anant Kumar hegde he's also
politician he has called the members of
the tablighi jamaat group terrorists by
with a forget who is a famous wrestler
who is also very popular in social media
and a member of the BJP has linked the
spread of corona virus to the table key
jamaat this Muslim organization Kapil
Mishra again he basically said that
members of this group are infecting
people and I attempting to kill Indians
by spreading corona virus I mean is this
really what the BJP intends to do is
that the game plan what would you say to
this you may need to hear me out because
there are three questions late in one
first article 19 of our Constitution our
calls freedom of speech expression to
every Indian and it incorporates
everyone was appointed and that includes
destroyed as it includes any one of the
other names you say number two with
regard to the members of the public is
Emma tell me on what human standards on
what civilizational standards on what
standards of rule of law infected people
spitting on two health care workers is
to be taken as something pardonable
oil it against undressing before female
nurses
and be obscene about it so I mean we
need to bear in mind there have been
attacks they look at the video of indoor
where stones were pelted on health
workers and doctors including a Muslim
doctor working irrespective of caste
community creed or religion so what you
see is the point so what you're saying
is that Muslims in India are primarily
responsible for the spread of korvac 19
these points which we have pointed out
of bed apivita single or abundant
commodity are their views as a party and
more importantly as the common not an
action act policy distinguishes or makes
a comparative between any Indian citizen
particularly on race religion caste
creed or planet that is what the
Constitution does say but the fact is
the members of the BJP are saying what
they are saying what would you say to
that that was my question [ __ ] as
also the Constitution says that so these
exactly you have to take everything with
a pinch of salt I speak here I have
showed you real examples of members of
your parties saying what they are saying
you point
it's a viewpoint of a ruling party sir
and after that there have been attacks
against Muslims Muslims distributing
food have been stopped a lot of other
Muslims have been attacked in Karnataka
for instance these examples are there
but I just like to ask you one overall
question just to sort of reassure the
viewers who are watching this broadcast
are you saying that Muslims under
Muslims in India can feel safe in India
under the current terrains remove the
government to Hindu priests siddhu's
will leash to death by a Muslim crowd
our government of course the state has
taken action and the government of Meryn
as always we are victim of eccentric the
victim has to get the protection the
perpetrator irrespective of being Hindu
Muslim or any other religion action has
to be against them right now so answer
your question yes this is coming for
every Indian and every Indian means an
Indian irrespective of their religion
their region red caste they gender and
that's why there is not a scheme or a
policy or an act of narendra modi's
comedy that has ever been discriminatory
to Indians in any way and that's my
challenge show me what there's a number
of comebacks to that but then we'd have
to leave it there for the time being
not in Kodi making it clear he's a
lawyer making the case for the BJP thank
you very much for joining us